je vais vous proposer un jeu dans
l'écran passe afficher une photo vous
allez devoir me dire ce que vous en
pensez
l'accord pourrait réagir également les
autres mais voulait c'est anne d'abord
c'est parti premières photos attention
qu'est ce que vous pensez voilà ils sont
en train de caler psych encore dans la
roumanoff la faune google roumanoff
r oh merci qu'est ce que vous pensez du
divorce
bon qu'est ce que j'en pense bah ouais
vas des fois on n'a pas le choix suite
logique qu'ils allaient divorcer vous
ouais comme une fois à non pas comme lui
spectacle parler de la mission théval
c'est avec le divorce et c'est ce qui
est le plus cher dans libre maintenant
mais c'est c'est ça peut il ya des
moments c'est difficile et après ça va
csh c1 c'est un bouleversement dans la
vie justement j'étais 25 ans donc ouais
c'est pas tous les trois ans - bah oui
c'est vrai il faut se calmer mieux c'est
une part contrat de mariage ici le débo
avez vu comme j'ai fait là ça ici ils le
font ici assez vite perdre petit peu de
gens le font piéger quel niveau puis
pardon quand on aime on ne compte pas
mais quand on aime plus qu'est-ce qu'on
combat le rsa vous avait divorcé vous
non maintenant jamais comme modéré de
mariage 40-41 le 14 octobre 41 c'est
après tout de mon père sait où vont ces
importants sont attendus de voiture l'a
déjà divorcé d'avec jean michel mr bah
moi vous françois viot oui j'ai divorcé
ben c'est un très mauvais souvenir c'est
réparé personnes
soulagement c'est vrai c'est un gars de
la presse anglaise bien sûr vous allez
divorce et non trente ans de mariage ce
serait content de voir ce vin en plus
dur et oui à la salle grand choix en
plus avec ce que tu prends cette année
sur ses vols jeudi la vérité et évite le
divorce quoi penses tu avais jamais
divorcé toi ici est à san luis et l'ap
est divorcée ne sais pas mais jamais
dire jamais divorcé fidèles défilent
tout paquet ce cas elles mêmes qu'au
palais la même heure
j'allais dire les mêmes of drôle là
dessus oui bah merci mon lait c'est quoi
c'est quoi l'histoire très le couple de
100 ans qui divorcent et quelques lignes
mais vous êtes fous de d'ivoire c'est
maintenant à 100 en faveur on attendait
que jean-françois morts
poulin l'appât du gain et j'ai bossé
tout ce que j'aime ravon les adolescents
si vous pensez des adolescents qu'elle
ratera ce qu'est ce que j'en pense je
veux pas de problème j'ai des
adolescents chez moi vous avez combien
d'enfants 2 200 quel âge dans une quête
plus adolescentes mais je n 2 qui
regardent la salle attelage travail à
laquelle âge elle va avoir 17
il s'étend l'oncle classe elle rentre
banon elle est en terminale là c'est
sérieux ayant ya un bac
non il ya un dst mercredi en maths de
voir sur capdemat mollo sa grand-mère
aux copains des stés mercredi oui quelle
race sera ça veut dire tu dors pas
dimanche l'inde et lui qu'elle travaille
non elle voit une écoute regarde
l'émission va parler match moyen c'est
le meilleur moyen de révision alice est
le meilleur moyen elle s'appelle comment
marie il marie steph un gros bisou ma
chérie voilà je t'embrasse et t'inquiète
pas tu vas avoir le bac tangwa spa
station je vous le dire
l'année du bac ça sert à rien d mais je
le dis quand sert à rien d'être bon
pendant l'année
il faut être bon de jours que maxime a
toujours été avec moi j'étais une bonne
à toute l'année et bascule bac mon frère
on est en 2010 leone en 2019 arrêtez
avec vos dates l'a arrêté oui il ya le
contrôle continu mais ça ça coûte moins
que le bac faut être là au bon moment
s'est arrêté allez vas t'amuser et mon
bébé
elle ratera quentin de voir ce tableau
car tu dors pas moi je me réveillais
pendant la nuit
vous savez vous étiez vous mais non mais
je vous disais c'est relou pour les
autres m'en fous moi du tout j'ai des
victoires et on passera mais c'est vous
n'avez jamais révisé pour un dst ou pour
un pour un chameau loin jamais jamais le
bon exemple de très bonnes facultés
non mais j'étais pas je n'étais pas là
dedans j'étais pas là dedans sms de
voter alors bientôt ses excuses c'est ce
que je me dis je me disais on verra sur
place
j'étais persuadé à chaque fois qu'elle
allait arriver un contrôle mon frère
maintenant je connais rien sur rien et
j'ai pu persuader qu'elle avoir un
miracle je me suis dit il va se passer
quelque chose on contrôle un miracle un
cam qui va arriver qui va apparaître
comme un scandale
non mon frère vous n'avez jamais en fait
jarry mais il n'y a jamais eu de miracle
pour que jamais on a pris une leçon
d'histoire
jamais jamais jamais j'ai ça va arriver
lâche et le faire qu'est ce que pour
city thunder kinder bat indoor moi je
peux pas y aller parce que je suis connu
un tiret vous aurez vous pourriez
trouver un mec sur steam d'heure ben non
je peux pas parce que si je mets une
fausse photo après et et ben ils voient
ouais ça va pas il va être content le
confrère ben non mais non mais sait on
peut pas content de le nommer mais où
j'ai tenté
[Rires]
vous dire vous vous bonifier avec le
temps d'être de plus en plus belles
dents mais franchement c'est vrai c'est
un truc de fou
je vois que vous êtes voilà ça y est là
et on voit qu'elle a divorcé celle ci
fait remarquer tous les gens qui
divorcent que soient les hommes
deviennent ado quand ils divorcent
frères ils disent ni coup ni connus
comme les reflets d'or ils refont les
voeux chapelet refont le front email
griffes et ils sortent ils vont acheter
des affaires sans rigoler pour relancer
la croissance vont divorcer
non mais je te jure la croissance
économique les mecs qu'ils ont envie
d'acheter ils ont envie de tout faire
c'est un truc de fou je te jure divorce
toi tu vas voir tu as toujours à ce
qu'est ce que tu penses de un nom voilà
qu'est ce que tu penses de qu'est ce que
tu penses de balances ton port moi je
pense à travers vraiment sa vie si on en
a parlé maintes et maintes fois ci si je
trouve ça très bien parce que même si ça
a été un peu excessive j'ai fait un
texte est reçue dans mon spectacle je
sais mais il faut il faut que les choses
sortent donc il ya eu tout un il ya
beaucoup de gens qui allaient changer
les mentalités mais vraiment eaux
profondes à je pense ça vraiment changer
la mentalité et c'est vrai que mon après
comme le disait géraldine du radis
navets peur voilà d'une dérive et que
les relations entre les deux hommes à
l'amérindienne puisse plus être les
mêmes
appelé comme aux états unis mais c'est
vrai que tu en parles dans tous les 5
ans dans l'après bien ça commence à
avoir les hommes et les femmes ça
commence à faire de faire là bas
oui bien sûr il faut juste avoir blais
faut juste avoir du respect pour la
marque de respect ça devient oies
blanches mais voilà après on va voir
mais je pense que c'était important
quand même